君を
[音楽]
goo
あああ
[音楽]
やばいってこの広さ一人でスイートルームです
こんにちははじめしたそうですよ山梨県が富士急ハイランドに来て俺めっちゃ素肌何も
朝の質じゃあなんですけども
そしても退園前に地下できない曲がありましてそれを今日やっていきたいと思いますは
にまあ相場下がってきたさんがいるんですけど遊びに行けば勝利
8席の中小嶋富士急に2人で来ております駄文そうマナー
絶鬼を嫌いなんですよ絶叫嫌いなんですけどもなんとか気合いで富士宮の
これ最強の絶叫のちょっと藤永に1回乗せたら
開演前だでお客さんいないわけですねまぁ先にスタッフの方を話し合ってるんですけど
も
いやまよ良い縁に留まらないとき
ていきたいとおもいますどこ外はでいっって言ったら戻って折れるんですけども下りず
にそのままた発射してしまう
それを時間で打つ気になったようになって無事へ正永に降りれない時やりたいと思い
ますお客さんいたら普通を受けなきゃいけないんでホット開演前にしかできないもんね
ずっとできないような企画になっておりますし
澤さん
メイクハッピー仏教好きですか
在京ねはいは嫌いですねあそっかぁ残念だ今日はですね
藤山によってみたいもう行った時一回切っ外題時間1回になれば大丈夫なんです
富士急飲み物まで一件も乗ったことないんだよグレープ人生で者でも大丈夫されるため
になる
ブーブー
頑張る落ちたどれ増えます
じゃまああれですねあのこれですまじか降りたべく多忙なライジャむしろラーメンのと
ピュアまぁこられますある
イベ毒てはない住んでを送ってない今はさせず具合なのでこれでこれでそれでこれ
田所待ってもういいなんでー
ad 方って本当に立海でも大丈夫だろう言ってんだよね
1回3 p なんか大丈夫乗るのは1回
[音楽]
me
ni
俺がチョウォンジョンいい本
dare
イベ行きます待って者だってマジやばくない
ああああああ
me
nome 行ってきません
やだとめっちゃめっちゃ電極だろうですよねー
4ランサーだ俺も嫌なんですよ
まだもう一回やっちゃえば終わりなんだよただし一度よろしい me
amaran
delan
よくなりますバイヤーとまとうだけ落ちるううう
car
can you do
dj
うわぁ he
samy フリフバブ打ってたこぶえネイバー
ああああああ
me
ああああああああ
dj ren
[音楽]
wh
[拍手]
goo
rar
amaran
uh
me
nu do re
ポカ can can
re j ホラーですこの
セキュリティーズ同じん
[拍手]
ブーブー1間
西条大丈夫だっはぁはぁっ
ん ana
me
car
へいへい
ええええええ
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
ああああああ
9割超え
wh
akinori
cani
ああああああ
ちょっとなれますかグレー
ブーブー
debian あ
amaran
rar
maremare
1回しかのぐらいです日顕宗載ってない俺ないください
まだ続いてるんでそれ oksana やー
wh
[音楽]
amaran
ana
tee
[音楽]
wh
ネイル慣れてないです行ってきます
eel いやこれは結構綺麗ですねー
甘い力入れてない麻薬を出そう
car
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
なんで5回目北海道ですその後海面社員です
じゃあ見てくだ俺力みすぎてなサーモン他のものリストカット設定など強い
それ
tee
[音楽]
car
me
ご乗車地から脱いで打っていれば
力強く良い日を貼っ初めてこれらさぁそれではまた
usahana
car
ああああああ
me
ボール立ちア世界の未来なってるって言われたんだそれ
でございますじゃ塗っちゃった毛を剃る入ってまーす
n あって俺めっちゃ最後だと思ってませんねえじゃあ
始めたと思ってた俺モーターさん
待ってる aa
car
me
ストレスざーはいどーするのはいいんでしょ怖いけど安全はわかったじゃないですか
だからここからどうぞしか見てねバイバイドロンに合わせないよ
na na na na
me
rar
イェーイだってみましたねー
[音楽]
re おりカードもこれはですね色吐息とかもすごいん
me
nan まずまでです良いから抜いて体を前に倒しましょう
空はいオッケー
re re re re re re
したきますよ
[音楽]
taian
tan
ganbare
ええええええ
おりまーす
[音楽]
amaran
ディスプレイしてしたきてる b ありません
me
nan
カゲロウデイズ
amaran
na na na na
tan
ええええええ
wh
jan
ええええええ
handjob
[音楽]
ブーブー言っに
ちょっと新しいヘアー最初入ってから嫌でも1回しか売ってないんでどのように長いし
ました
そうな一回しか乗ってないんですよ
驚いたり恋だけですねー
藤山僕から無限に回り続ける
ドッキリどうでした無理ですねでも実際
けどやってからちょっと楽な感じのコースで見えてるだろって言うが
一番挑戦が見え見えますね駄目だ
踊った
また乗るか乗らないかベルト乗らないどれに乗りますよ撮れませもうちょっと走らない
ぞまあ真ゲッターで乗りたい
楽しい所なんですけどしばらくいざ不調でねー
しばらくそれぞれで今回の動画でまた一つものことをやっぱ継続たということが分かり
ました
re なるって求め話がいたしてマジで何でもできるいらっしゃいください
確かにそれもあってかまた声臨みましょうぜってーです